hello BuzzFeed I'm Paul Rudd I'm
generator hi I'm Chris Evans and I'm
Mark Ruffalo I'm Karen Gillan I am then
I grita
avec I'm Bree Larson I'm Chris Hemsworth
I'm done
blossom so we're taking a quiz to see if
we would survive the defense's snap and
you're watching stuff online
[Music]
which affinity stone would you most like
to get your hands on
yeah there's reality power Monde times
solo spice what do you guys think the
one I least understand is probably
reality stone come on power Gus I'm
going so one time I like space I'm along
with space I even know what that means
I'm going with time everyone wishes they
could have a time machine right so I'm
gonna take time Doug Doug Doug stone the
Doug stone by the way right I love done
stone is that a good what's he up to
I picked the mind stone because it's
yellow I mean I'm going mind I'm going
time which Disney character would you
choose to join The Avengers Queen Elsa
Hercules genie from Aladdin sorcerer
Mickey that's the girl
dope and Stitch Janey much as I love
sorcerer Mickey it's less elastic oh it
sounded edgy I want genie
yeah I'll go the g2 I feel like I'm
gonna feel I mean Hercules feels like
just on a strength level although the
genie providing three wishes could be
really vital and being Thanos because
it's like oh no we failed but like could
I have a wish to just try that again I'm
going with Queen Elsa why are you bad
ass it's kind of who I'm going with
- who didn't on sorcerer Mickey is
really I'm tempted I mean there's
there's function and then there's just
person I'm gonna go from the standpoint
of function it's got to be genie I'm
gonna change you know which word would
you Jesus I can't even read neither can
i we need education pack yes you a which
word would your closest friends use to
describe you caring loyal creative funny
kind successful the most hilarious human
that doesn't suit me yeah let's see that
in here I don't see my due north
I'm sorry
I'd go create carry all your cursor
thought about
caring it is caring discuss caryharri
caring I hope kind we are not going to
survive we're kind people who love the
genie creative I like to think somebody
actually brought me a pair glass
oh that's a sweet this help that's why
I'm worthy for fun guys gonna wear
glasses breathing thick so you choose I
choose loyal yeah I can see you are a
loyal friend I am to a fault I'm gonna
choose successful okay sure I think my
buddies would say loyal oh sure they
would say one which is your favorite MCU
dynamic duo hope and Scott mmm I wonder
which one you're gonna pour and Loki
Steven Bucky science bro is a Kimora a
nebula Carol and fury
I mean it's Kimora and nebula come on
let's not be around the bush
I'm gonna go caroling fury yeah me too
because I'm actually this awesome
you can't believe in yourself right
that's a real that would be lame right
I'm gonna back myself you're gonna pick
yourself and of course you didn't pick
himself cool
I'm gonna think more an ambulance I
didn't mean to do that no no I think it
was meant to be it was the same I'm
gonna go with the science pros and you
are not just cuz you're here just be
kind of going with Steve and Bucky head
of boy that's not why I did it I I had
to pick hope and Scott and of course
that's right really obligated I picked
them you did by the way you know what
that is that's loyal which weirder
unconventional superpower would you want
to possess the power to instantaneously
learn any language by only hearing at
once I already love that one the power
to change the nutritional value of any
food to your well that's even better
I could turn chocolate into kale the
power to remember anything you read and
recall it instantly I can't even recall
the questions I'm just the power to make
any and all clothing items fit you
perfectly as if Taylor keep it that
you're an [ __ ] yeah that's better
than learning every language yeah
totally
the power to transform into any animal
you can
think of real or imaginary or that's
sick
the power to always know with absolute
certainty when someone is lying that
you've you have to reassess your life
I'm gonna have to have the power to know
what's absolute certainty when someone
is lying
well that flies in the face of what I
just mumbled under my breath okay I
think I wanna go the animal now I'm
gonna do the language thing I'm sorry
going the transformation flying post
thing one like old pegasi pegasister
thanks me I want to be the animal I
think I'm gonna go up the lying I'm
gonna go with the power to remember
anything you read and recall it
instantly I'm going learn any language
by only hearing at once I'm going with
the language and dominating the planet
power of nutritional value of any food I
guarantee you once it happens I could
doughnut right yeah do you like
doughnuts yeah do it treats additional
value of it it's all something get
seasick
crud what if it got here your mind is
made up Jeremy who's origin story is
your personal favorite yeah you know
that's Tony Stark
Steve Rogers which by the way when I
took a quick look at SRI sick [ __ ]
anybody thought it was broken in home
alone there's nothing super about this
hero Thor Carol Danvers he spent like
five minutes up in this a lot of
geniuses origin story I'm gonna go away
mine wait there's no any start nothing
I'm going to Charlotte
I'm gonna get you Carol please my best
friend I don't think we're that close
Mary Kirsten yeah those dyed eyebrows
I'm gonna go with Carol Danvers on that
one I have to go with my king she's
partial that's all right she's a very
loyal person it's Carol Danvers I'm
gonna go as Steve Rogers I mean look at
that
boy tell you what I love that you know
if you were on there I would vote for
you yes Lee thank you I'm gonna go at 25
I'm going Tony Stark I'm gonna go ahead
kid
this guy feel bad Zima give him a banana
and finally what would you say is your
personal character flaw
where's none we know here's the coconut
box one for Chris Hanna they all have a
short temper I care too deeply that's
like speed dating I can be a little too
blunt I'm always confident I can be a
little reckless okay we should pick each
other's ready okay yeah yeah then you
can be a little too blunt a little
reckless I can't I can't you're a temper
okay I'm gonna say I'm not always
confident I can be a little too blunt
I'm clicking hey maybe I can be a little
I'm going what that can be a little too
blunt this is surprising I have a short
temper really yeah
I think I'm joking around too much let's
be honest oh just bring joy to people's
lives didn't know that was a problem
hey you got Capgras congratulations you
made it
the mighty Thanos Thanos how do you
pronounce it thermos
it has spared your life but completely
at random
still let's don't crash near luck so my
actually says congratulations you made
it you are the best most inspiring
person that's your desk retake quiz No
oh you're not feeling so good no I'm
sorry I want to tell you this but you
did not survive the piano snap so the
Avengers will do whatever it takes to
write this injustice so rest easy my
friend I can't believe I didn't survive
but I survived on the screen I do about
this that sucks man this is bull man and
then young couple find their dream home
for their fur baby you can see the
difference in at least six of these
colors I'll be seriously impressed